my flagship proposals we give every
American a thousand dollars a month
Korean clear if you know you have a
little bit more freedom from scarcity
then you can start making moves towards
the sort of work that you want for
yourself that you value that you would
find fulfilling and exciting
hello and welcome to the sunday special
we're joined this week by Andrew yang
author of the book the war on normal
people I can't wait to get to my
conversation with Andrew but first can
you believe it's already April time has
a habit of getting away but if you have
a mortgage or kids or anyone depending
on your income you're gonna have to
spend some of that time getting life
insurance if you need life insurance but
you don't want to spend a lot of time
comparing it
you should give policy genius a try
policy genius is the easy way to buy
life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers and find your best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape no Commission's no hidden fees just
more time saved for you and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also make it easy to find the
right home insurance or auto insurance
or disability insurance their one-stop
shop for financial protection so if you
need life insurance but you're short on
time head on over to policy genius comm
and compare quotes how genius is easy it
saves you money and not to belabor the
point but it is indeed fast policy
genius spend less time comparing life
insurance more time doing literally
anything else it's the responsible thing
to do you're an adult gotta take care of
your family I know you don't think
you're gonna die tomorrow but the fact
is you don't know and that's why you
ought to be checking out policy genius
right now it's not gonna cost you a lot
of time and you'll be doing something
valuable for yourself and your family
policy genius spend less time comparing
life insurance more time doing literally
anything else on planet earth policy
genius.com
that's policy genius calm go check it
out right now hi Andrew thanks so much
for coming by the show really appreciate
it oh it's great to be here thanks for
having me
well first of all I just have to thank
you again for coming on the show because
we've invited a lot of folks on the left
particularly members of the Democratic
Party who are running for president
you're the only person who's accepted
thus far and so we appreciate the
conversation it really does mean a lot
to me that you would come on and I'm
sure that you will get some slings and
arrows for it well I hope I can set a
trend like I hope I'm the first but not
the last so let's start with this where
what prompted you to run for president
where are you where are you coming from
what's what's your backstory for folks
who don't know you so I certainly was
not one of these kids who grew up
thinking they were going to run for
president I was born in upstate New York
my parents are immigrants from Taiwan
they met in graduate school at UC
Berkeley so my father was an engineer
for GE and IBM he generated 69 US
patents over his career and being an
academic is sort of the family business
my dad's a professor in
my brother is a professor and my
grandfather was a professor so I like
you went to law school I went to you
know I started economics in political
science in college do you know what to
do so I went to law school and then
practice law for five unhappy months and
then left to start in ill-fated calm in
the first bubble but then I have been
bitten by the bug and said this is much
better than being an unhappy lawyer and
so I worked at a healthcare software
company and then I became the head of an
education company that grew to become
number one in the US and was acquired by
a public company in 2009 so at this
point my you know career was going
really well but it was the wake of the
financial crisis and I thought that we
had all of these whiz kids heading to
Wall Street and McKinsey and not enough
starting generative businesses and
places like Detroit or Cleveland or
Baltimore or st. Louis so I quit my job
I started an organization called venture
for America that helped create several
thousand jobs in those cities and
another dozen cities or so around the
u.s. and the reason I'm running for
president is that when you spend time in
the Midwest in the south you see the
aftermath of the fact that we automated
away four million manufacturing jobs in
Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Missouri Iowa all the swing states that
Trump needed to win and did win and so
I'm running for president to wake up
America to the fact that it is not
immigrants that are causing economic
problems it is the fact that we're going
through the greatest economic and
technological transformation in the
history of the country it's called the
fourth Industrial Revolution and we need
to progress to the next stage of
capitalism in order for our country to
prosper and in age where artificial
intelligence and self-driving cars and
trucks will become real now you talk a
lot in the book there are normal people
about these people who are in the middle
of the country and whose talents are
sort of being left behind their jobs or
sort of being left behind do you think
that the Democratic Party has properly
spoken to a lot of those people there's
a feeling that President Trump one
specifically because the Democratic
Party largely forgot about those folks
well to me there's a very powerful
central economic narrative where if you
look at the voting district data there's
literally a straight line up between the
adoption of industrial automation in an
area and the movement towards Donald
Trump and so to me Democrats need to try
and address that set of problems
if they fail in that then then they're
not trying to solve the problems I got
Donald Trump elected like Donald Trump
is not himself
well he's to me a manifestation of this
greater economic mega trend and it's up
to the Democratic Party in my opinion to
help America navigate this wave as
opposed to focusing too much Donald
Trump who to me is a symptom now there's
been a lot of talk about the the
effective automation and some folks have
talked to you know sitting in your chair
have suggested solutions to automation
including restriction of automation
itself Tucker Carlson suggested on my
show for example that he wanted to
actually legislate away self-driving
trucks you don't make any of those sorts
of sweeping pronouncements about
limiting technology really in your book
no I'm very Pro Progress genuine
generally you know I think there might
be isolated instances where you need to
at least try and buy some time because
and I you know I talk about truckers a
fair amount in my book where being a
truck driver is the most common job in
29 states three and a half million truck
drivers ninety four percent men average
age 49 now and so if you can foresee
that you might displace ten tens or
hundreds of thousands of these truck
drivers over a particular period of time
you might want to slow that down because
you might need to buy yourself time to
help assimilate that adjustment but
generally speaking trying to just like
stop automation is a loser over time
because you might even be able to like
stick your finger in one part of the dam
but then something else is gonna break
anyway it's like you know like if we
tried to automate a way to say hey you
can't automate truck truck driving then
there would be some other part of the
economy where you'd look at it and say
well I guess we're gonna automate away
the warehouse workers when automated way
the dock workers like you can't stop at
all so with all of that said you know
the solutions that you propose are
pretty big government solutions you're a
guy who obviously worked in the private
sector and you ran a charity that was
specifically designed for helping people
in in the sector why do you think that
stuff is is insufficient why isn't it
that that it should just be about
private charity for example it's been my
proposal is that there needs to be a lot
more upswing and private charity that we
need to encourage people to leave some
of these dying towns you seem to suggest
that these people should essentially be
able to stay in these dying towns and
that government should take care of them
there well I think
I think there are several paths forward
but we have to choose one and we have to
figure out together it's like what is
the path forward for many many Americans
and the reason why I am confident that
we need to go bigger is that I was one
of the most celebrated social
entrepreneurs of the last number of
years where I started this multi-million
dollar organization venture for America
you know movie made about us honored by
the White House and I realized that our
efforts as much as I was proud of them
were like pouring water into a bathtub
as a giant hole ripped in the bottom
just the scale is all wrong where if you
look at the numbers we're looking at
three to four times the level of labor
force displacement as the first
Industrial Revolution or the Industrial
Revolution at the turn of the century
and so if you say hey charities are
gonna handle that like charities don't
have the scale to address needs this big
and I know this because I've worked in
that space and I you know hung out with
the heads of foundations and just the
scale is wrong for the scope of the
changes let's talk about the crisis
itself so the the book in period of the
first half is is rather dystopian about
kind of its description of the economy
particularly in certain parts and you do
make sort of a bifurcation between big
cities where you say the economy is
growing and some of the outlying rural
areas where you say that it's not
growing what about the argument that the
economy seems to be doing pretty well
that every time there's a technological
change historically there's been worker
displacement that there will be people
left behind because that's just the
nature of creative destruction but that
new jobs will be created in ways that we
can't foresee right now what makes you
think that this time is sort of the
Cataclysm well we 100% create many many
new jobs that we can't predict and the
issue is that they're going to be for
different people in different places
with different skills than the people
that are going to lose their jobs like
are gonna be able to take advantage of
and so if you look at a couple of big
historical references number one the
Industrial Revolution which people
generally refer to and say hey we've
been through this before the Industrial
Revolution at the turn of the century
included mass riots that killed dozens
of Americans and caused billions of
dollars worth of damage we now have
Labor Day as a national holiday because
of those riots we implemented universal
high school in 1911 and part as a
response to these problems and pain and
McKinsey project that this time
is going to be three to four times
faster and larger than that Industrial
Revolution in terms of displacement
workers so even if you just rely upon
history you would expect a lot of
violence and tumult and conflict number
two I studied economics in college and
according to economic theory if you were
to automate away four million
manufacturing jobs which we did those
workers would move get retrained
rescaled find new higher productivity
jobs and all would be well but when I
dug into the numbers it turns out that
almost half of those workers left the
workforce and never worked again and of
that group about half fob for disability
and then you saw a surge in substance
abuse and drug overdoses and suicides
none of which were in my economics
textbook it didn't say hey like workers
aren't gonna go home for disability and
start dying at record levels so if you
look at that fact pattern you say okay
that's what happened when four million
manufacturing workers lost their jobs
that's actually a much better sign of
what's going to happen when the three
and a half million truckers and the two
and a half million call center worker
isn't the over ten million retail
workers suffer from the same sort of
displacement know the conservative
counter-argument to some of what you're
talking about it would be right all
these people went on disability but they
were able to meaning that a lot of
people were able to find a social safety
net they've been reliant on that social
safety net that hasn't actually rebuilt
the forms of social capital necessary to
have functioning societies you've seen
people who are supported by the
government largely who are still getting
addicted to drugs people who are in
court committing suicide at record rates
who are staying unemployed for years at
a time and who are staying in towns
where presumably they really shouldn't
be staying I mean there are seven
million unfilled jobs apparently in the
United States right now and there are a
lot of people who are out of work and
people as you mentioned in the book are
basically staying where they are is the
incentive structure may be misaligned
because of government intervention into
the system you know it's a very
interesting question and one of the
things that I found worrisome in the
data was that Americans are migrating
between states at multi-decade lows
which is a terrible sign for dynamism
and I love dynamism I mean I think
people should be moving for for work
it's very good economically and
culturally it's something very
optimistic about moving to some to
another state for a new job and so I
would love to help more Americans do
just that and one
my policy proposals that we pay moving
expenses for Americans who want to move
because to your point there are a lot of
Americans who are stuck in place because
they're underwater and a mortgage there
are costs associated with a move that
they can't manage but a lot of them are
also in place because they have families
and so it's tough if you're going
through a hard time and then you have
like the only people that you're close
to in your life are living in that same
town and then you're like hey guys I'm
going to leave to move to the big city
you know you're asking people in some
ways to sacrifice what little they can
rely upon in their lives I mean and I
think that that's sort of where I am in
the sense that I wonder if this is more
about an American mentality shift that
has to happen as opposed to government
intervention ISM so maybe we need to
reinstall the sort of pioneer ethos that
supposedly animated the United States in
the first place this idea okay you do
have to pick up and you do have to move
and you do have to make difficult
decisions to better your economic life
and do you ever worry that the
description of the upcoming economic
catastrophe is actually disincentivizing
people from from going out and trying to
forge forth because I do think that how
people think has a major impact on how
they decide to embrace the job market
well you know like you say you know I
mean facts are very stubborn things and
so you know like I'm convinced that
we're let's say for example 30 percent
of American malls are gonna close in the
next four years and working in retail
the most common job in America I mean
those are objective facts like Amazon
sucking up another twenty billion
dollars in commerce every year and so
saying hey this is happening I don't
think that necessarily is going to
freeze people in place like the hope is
that we can galvanize energy around
folks trying to improve their situations
and adopting real solutions but I
couldn't agree with you more that there
is a mindset that we would love to have
more Americans inhabit and and what I'm
going to suggest is that there's
something very optimistic and confident
about that pioneer ethos that you
describe which is like hey I'm just like
go and we're gonna make it happen I'm
gonna farm you know and some
undiscovered frontier and like we're
gonna create a better life for ourselves
and that is not happening for a lot of
Americans so the question is how do we
get them from where they are now the
to that point I want to ask you about
your perspective on jobs because it
seems like you have an interesting view
of jobs on the one hand you say that
people obviously need them they need
them for a sense of meaning on the other
hand you seem to suggest that those jobs
aren't forthcoming anytime soon so do
you think that it's the jobs that
provide meaning or the check that
provides meaning they at one point in
your book for example you specifically
criticize this this exact bifurcation
you you basically say that there are two
completely oppositional ideas page 182
to completely oppositional ideas that
many people seem to hold simultaneously
first work is vital and the core of
human experience second no one will want
to work if they don't have to well where
do you stand on that do you think that
work is vital and people are going to
work or do you think that work is not
vital and that this whole can sort of be
filled by the government paying for it
so I assume that you you believe work is
vital I mean you talk a lot about it in
the book and you're you're you know
opposing that to the idea that people
won't work if they don't have to but
you're acknowledging a lot of people
aren't going to work I mean your basic
government proposals involve a lot of
paying people whether they're working or
not obviously with the goal that we
create more work because I'm very much
in the work is a vital camp and that's
not just my thinking about it that's
just in the data where if you look at
what happens to idle men in particular
we spend a lot of time on the computer
playing video games and doing other
things we volunteer less than employed
men even though we have more time our
drinking and substance abuse tends to go
up and over time there are some
antisocial patterns that develop in idle
men to a higher degree than women and so
that's just data and so if you look at
that you say okay this actually is
pretty consistent with my intuition that
work is incredibly important and vital
it provides structure purpose
fulfillment meaning social structures to
them to people every day and so the
question is how do we create more things
like that now to me the best path to
create that is to put economic resources
into people's hands in the form of a
freedom dividend of $1,000 a month which
would then allow more people to do the
sort of work that either they want to do
or that their community has a need for
and the goal is to create jobs and
putting a thousand bucks a month into
people's hands would create at least two
million new jobs just because
the buying power would just go right
back into local businesses and
communities now all that being said I do
think our definition our notion of work
should evolve and one example I use my
wife is at home we're talking about our
families my wife is at home with our two
young boys one of whom is autistic and
right now she works very hard I mean she
you know like she works harder than than
I do as Nina you know I mean I'm running
for president and she's working harder
but the market values her work at zero
society in some ways you know minimizes
the value of that work and so to me we
should broaden the net definitions of
work to include being a parent or
caregiver but also arts creativity
entrepreneurship journalism things that
we know people coaching volunteering
civic engagement people things that we
know people want to do more of but that
right now society will systematically
either under value or not provide not
have any monetary value so I want to ask
you about the location of meaning so
I've heard as I say I think there's a
point where the populist left sort of
meets the populist right and the
suggestion is that if we structure the
economy in certain ways that this will
provide more jobs and that the jobs are
what are going to provide meaning but
you also suggest that you know the
freedom dividend well it may create more
jobs as a sort of an ancillary benefit
there are a lot of people who are not
going to be able to work we're going to
be on the the freedom dividend who are
going to be receiving ubi in fact ubi
studies don't show increased employment
in virtually any study at best they show
even employment or declines in
employment in the areas in which they
are tried so we're and then you sort of
suggest that people will be able to find
meaning and all the other things you're
talking about volunteering and community
and art but we're not seeing that with
disability so people are dependent on
disability they're not engaging more in
art making or learning to play violin or
volunteering more they're engaging more
with video games as you talked about or
drug use or in some cases they become
suicidal we're seeing family breakdown
with all of that so what makes you think
the freedom dividend is going to have a
different effect on human behavior than
for example current government welfare
systems have yes so three things the
first is that money does not somehow
convey meaning and you know the best it
can do is maybe provide circumstances
that
people find a path towards the some work
that they find fulfilling the second
thing is I have a friend whose sisters
on disability and she's afraid to
volunteer in her community because she's
afraid she'd be noticed as able-bodied
and thus lose her benefits and so this
freedom dividend would be unconditional
and free and clear and so that person
would be volunteering and would not have
any fear that you know her benefits
gonna be taken away the third thing is
that there's something very very
important about conceiving yourself
yourself is either able or disabled and
so if you are literally getting a check
for being disabled your two ideas of
yourself are one I'm genuinely disabled
which and most people do have some kind
of genuine ailment you know physical or
mental or - I'm defrauding our society
and I'm actually totally fine and I'm
gonna suggest that most people will fall
into bucket number one that it's like a
rare person who's just like I am a
hundred percent fine there's a
disability check I'm getting is just me
being completely fabricating some-some
condition and so if you invert that
mentality and you say hey you are not
disabled you are fine you're a citizen
of the richest most advanced country in
the history of the world and you you're
getting this cash and it's gonna be
yours no matter what because it's yours
and you deserve it then that would be
more constructive in terms of pushing
more people into things that they'd feel
good about that society would feel good
about then if we say hey there's
something wrong with you and we're gonna
give you this cash in order to survive
so with all that said is your proposal
for essentially universal basic income
the freedom dividend do you see that as
substituting for the vast agglomeration
of welfare state policies we currently
have which was sort of Milton Friedman's
proposal or do you see it as another
dividend on top of whatever is being
paid we're already paying tens of
thousands of dollars per household in
poverty in the United States in in
welfare yes so my plan the freedom
dividend would be opt in but if you opt
in then you will forego benefits from
the existing programs and so if you are
currently receiving more than a thousand
dollars in benefits then you look at
this and say hey like I'm not going to
do anything and my life is going to be
as it is if you decide to opt in for the
freedom dividend and might be very
appealing because it's unconditional
there's no administration no case
manager
$1,000 cash you can do whatever you want
then you forego your current enrollment
and so what what you'd see is you'd see
we would shrink the role the enrollment
in the 126 or so different welfare
programs that we have and then over time
those enrollments would go down which is
very much the goal because the current
programs no one loves them and they do
have many unfortunate incentives
attached to them where if you do better
then you get less and so many people are
under reporting how they're doing or or
constructing a world where they are
maximizing their benefits so when we
talk about the cost of this thing and
you talk about in the book the more on
normal people you talk about it'll cost
maybe 1.3 trillion dollars a year that
would be in addition to current
budgeting presumably you know honestly
that's that's obviously a lot of
spending off the top but beyond that it
does raise the question as to would this
be limited in any way because every
government program as Ronald Reagan said
basically has a bill of the mortal life
and if it were to start at $1,000 a
month inflation adjusted how quickly
does this become somebody saying you
know it really ought to be $3,000 a
month because that's a popular pitch
everybody gets more free money where's
the logical limit on that and how do we
limit that from just eating the rest of
government because entitlement programs
obviously are running us ragged now they
obviously represent two-thirds of the
federal budget adding another massive
entitlement program on top that doesn't
have a limiting principle how do we
limit that so it doesn't become the
overarching goal of government and
actually put too much of a press on on
the capitalist system yes so the first
thing is I would disagree with the
characterization of a dividend as an
entitlement program and there's one
state that's had a dividend for 37 years
and that state is Alaska which is
deep-red was passed by a Republican
governor and he said look who would you
rather get the money the government
who's just gonna screw it up or you the
Alaskan people and the Alaskans said us
and he said I thought you'd say that and
then and now everyone in Alaska gets
between one in two thousand dollars a
year no questions asked it's created
thousands of jobs improved children's
health and nutrition its decreased
income inequality and here's the kicker
it's wildly popular in a deep red state
that hates taxes because they see it's
like this is one of the few things the
government gets right like I actually
get this dividend it's great I look
forward to it I it's real I can spend it
my kids get it like life is better
as a result and so like it's different
from an entitlement in both its
structure and the way it's utilized so
that's that's a big picture number one
number two is right now you're right
about the fact that our entitlement
programs are creeping ever higher in
terms of both proportion of the federal
budget and the enrollments we're there
right now more Americans on disability
than work in construction as one example
and these trends are not going to abate
they're actually going to accelerate so
the question is whether we're going to
try and restructure those programs to
something that we can all embrace and
get excited about that will actually
help keep American families and
communities strong instead of waiting
for more and more people to get
debilitated by for example an automation
wave that's going to displace the
significant proportion of the people
that hold the most common jobs in the
economy which we're in the midst of
right now and so the question is do you
wait and say okay like I guess we're
gonna have more and more people
qualifying for these welfare programs
that have very negative incentives
attached to them or are we going to own
the reality and say look we get it we're
going to have this dividend and then
we're going to reverse the incentives of
those programs over time now to your
question about like whether there's a
logical limit the reason why a thousand
dollars a month is so magical is that
it's enough to make a huge difference in
the lives of individuals and families
it's gonna help children's health and
graduation rates and mental health and
you know kids will have a real chance to
to learn will reduce domestic violence
will reduce hospital visits but it's not
enough to be a labor replacement because
$12,000 is below the u.s. poverty line
of twelve thousand seven hundred dollars
and so people are still gonna have to
work to prosper and have a life that
anyone's going to be excited about so my
goal would be to put in this thousand
now I did it end and then keep it at
that level but it's going to be up to
you you know and this is a big leap but
we have to trust that future legislative
legislators will be responsible for the
fact that yeah good luck to that well
but again you can look at something a
lot like Alaska they've had over 37
years and they've pegged it to a
particular resource and so what I'm
suggesting is what is the resource that
we should peg this to
and the resource we should peg this to
is technology where we have artificial
intelligence and self-driving cars and
trucks coming in Amazon this
trillion-dollar tech company that's
sucking up 20 billion dollars in
commerce and causing 30% of malls and
stores to close
they paid zero in federal taxes last
year and so what I'm going around saying
is like look that's not their fault it's
their job to pay as little tax as
possible but that means we've done a bad
job designing a system if Amazon's
paying less than federal taxes than you
are or you know he is that we focused a
lot on production but we very focus very
little in this conversation on
consumption and the fact is that you
know when we talk about sort of this
Halcyon past where everybody was
employed and people in manufacturing
industry were employed like you
described at one point in the 1970s and
I read because I think it's it's sort of
telling it interesting you say some
economic problems existed growth was
uneven an inflation periodically high
which might be a mild understatement I
mean the 70s were not great economically
but income inequality was low jobs
provided benefits and mainstream
businesses were the drivers of the
economy there were only three television
networks and in my house we watched them
on a TV with an antenna that we fiddled
with to make the picture clearer now I'm
not nostalgic for a time where I had
three channels on a TV where I had to
fiddle with the antenna there are
obviously benefits and drawbacks to the
economy but the fact is that people are
living significantly better on the
average in the United States than they
were in the 1970s if only from the
ability to consume more I mean the fact
is that we we everybody has a microwave
everybody has a cell phone everybody has
a car everybody
we're talking poverty line folks have
these things so when we talk about what
Amazon is not paying the fact is that
Amazon not only is one of the bigger
employers in the country but Amazon is
making legitimately millions of lives
better on the consumption side so are we
focusing too much on the production side
as opposed to the consumption side
especially considering that the number
of people who are affected by
consumption is 100% and the number of
people who are affected by lacks of
production jobs are significantly lower
than that well you know it's one of the
things that I say in the book which is
that if you have like this focus on
consumption like cheap stuff and access
to apps on your smartphone are great but
they don't substitute for having a
functioning Main Street or a job to
goto and so it's true that there are
winners and losers in this economy
unfortunately right now the losers are
outnumber the winners significantly by
these some measurements and we talked
about the 70s to now
income growth has stagnated for many
Americans from the 70s to now in real
terms and the last three years we've
seen this declining life expectancy
that's hand-in-hand with a surgeon
suicides and drug overdoses which is a
sign that at least some Americans are
experiencing the lack of productive
opportunity much more sharply than
having access to cheap consumer goods
can can somehow make up for well I think
that's obviously true for a subset of
the population it is also true that for
a hundred percent of the population the
consumer we got cheap stuff yeah I mean
coops that mean it's pretty fantastic
and great stuff and if the idea of ubi
is that raising living standards on a
generalized level results in in better
outcomes in a variety of areas then one
of the ways to do that is to continue to
provide that cheap stuff and so there
there is a balance here I would assume I
I like cheap stuff so let's talk about
your view of capitalism because I think
that there's there's something
interesting there so you talk about what
you call human capitalism the the idea
of changing our notion of capitalism
where we're essentially it changes how
we see the market you talk you say human
capitalism would have a few core tenets
one humanity is more important than
money to the unit of an economy is each
person not each dollar and three markets
exist to serve our common goals and
values one sort of an abstract in a
vacuum I agree with a lot of that stuff
obviously I mean I have kids I have
parents alright humans matter more than
money and if you asked me to sell my
child obviously the answer is no I like
my kids so you although it depends on
the day
if you're asking you know the units of
an economy dollars versus versus people
there I start to have a little more
trouble just on the economic level
because what I'm actually paying for is
a skill set not a person obviously the
value of each human being is infinite
but the value of these human beings
labor is certainly not and then when you
say markets exist to serve our common
goals and values this is what it's
really interesting because as I
mentioned mentioned Tucker because I
think that you and Tucker Carlson are on
the same page with regard to to some of
the stuff so Bernie Sanders for that
matter the idea that markets exist to
serve people I think is
something with which I disagree and I'll
explain when when we talk about markets
my view of a market is essentially a
recognition that my labor belongs to me
a free market is just my labor belongs
to me in the same way that free speech
is my viewpoint belongs to me you can't
say that the market exists to serve our
common goals any more than you say the
free speech exists to serve our common
goals free speech is just a recognition
that I as an individual human being have
Worth and so free markets are the same
thing as a recognition that I is an
individual human being my labor has
worth so the idea that the market is
just something that is an institution
that we have come up with together and
then we play with I'm not sure that's an
accurate description of what markets
actually represent there's an underlying
value to human labor that is not just a
common system we all decided to come up
with one day it's just a recognition
that I can alien at my labor and you can
buy my labor is that wrong well that so
to me the the fundamental shift that we
have to start getting our arms around is
that certain people's labor is not going
to be worth enough for them to make the
kind of living that is required for them
to live what they would consider a good
life and so if you look at look at truck
drivers as an example because I use them
as because they're the most like clear
so you have three half billion truckers
making about forty six thousand dollars
a year and and that it's a punishing job
they're behind the wheel of this truck
for up to 14 hours a day and they're
away from their families four days a
week and the rest of it but their market
value with the market of their their
time behind the wheel you know it's
about forty six thousand dollars a year
now
if five to ten years from now my friends
in Silicon Valley come up with trucks
that can largely drive themselves and
then you were gonna go to that truck
driver and say hey turns out your market
value like you're time behind the wheel
it's not 46,000 anymore it's twenty six
it's zero it's like what you know
whatever that the number is and so
there's like a like a change building up
in our economy that the freedom to trade
your labor for money to make a good
living for yourself it like that's
actually going to end up breaking down
in more and more situations where that
truck driver is not no less willing to
trade his time I mean he's still
to do it but then the the freight
company's gonna be like turns out your
times not worth what it was and it's not
just the trucker it could be a
radiologist who makes hundreds of
thousand dollars and they interpret
radiation films say I'm very willing to
do this like I like getting paid
hundreds of thousand dollars then we say
hey turns out that a I can see tumors
you can't can refer to millions of films
not thousands can see shades of gray
they're invisible to human eye you lose
your time all of a sudden goes from
worth $100,000 to let's call it you know
like half that or zero or whatever the
number is and so I I think that it
worked for a long time when the average
American could show up and say if I'm
willing to work hard I've got a strong
back like you know I can make a decent
living for myself my family like it was
in the seventies where if I showed up
even to a manufacturing plant I may be
able to provide a middle-class life for
myself and my family but then if that
stops working then we need to start
thinking differently about how the labor
market functions so if we've moved
beyond sort of the concept of free
markets as places where it can alienate
labor because some people are not
capable of alienating their labor their
labor is just not worth anything then is
the idea that the collective owns the
labor of everybody and gets to
redistribute the products of that labor
is that what we're talking about here
because the dicey territory no and I I
agree with that and that's actually the
outcome we have to avoid if at all
possible and this is one reason why my
flagship proposals we give every
American a thousand dollars a month free
and clear and that doesn't somehow usurp
your labor your time that actually if
anything liberates your your labor your
time that if you know you have a little
bit more freedom from scarcity then you
can start making moves towards the sort
of work that you want for yourself that
you value that you would find fulfilling
and exciting so one of the things that
you talk about and I think this is is
interesting because you are obviously a
big believer in the ability of people to
make choices with their own money and
this is why you believe in the freedom
dividend is the idea I'm giving you the
cash it's your decision what to do with
it at one point in the book you talked
about the idea that folks who are poorer
in the United States are actually good
with money that essentially that they
are going to be responsible with the
money that they have you say on page 185
the idea that poor people will be
irresponsible with their money and
squander it seems to be a product of
deep-seated bias
rather than emblematic of the truth and
you do this an internal broader attack
on the meritocratic idea in which you
say well you know this isn't completely
a meritocracy obviously there are some
people who are born into situations they
can't control you know always control
your own level of merit that sort of a
meritocratic myth and this is a position
that's held by people including Ross
doodad who's sort of a more populist
conservative at the new york times i
wonder however if if that's true and the
reason that I say that is because if you
look at the spending habits of people
who are lower down on the income chain
those spending habits don't tend to be
more frugal than people who are at the
upper levels of the income chain at
least not until those people at the
upper levels are pretty secure in being
at the upper levels you see conspicuous
consumption among people who are earning
in insane amounts of money because they
can afford it but the way that those
people largely became people who can
afford to do that is a certain level of
frugality I take for example the buying
of lottery tickets so the lowest income
households in the United States on
average spend four hundred and twelve
dollars annually on lottery tickets
almost three in ten Americans in the
lowest income bracket paid to play the
lottery once a week now we know just
statistically this is flushing your
money down the toilet it's complete
waste of time
there's no reason to do that and I
understand people do this out of despair
but that doesn't change the economic
truth which is that people may not make
good decisions with their money which is
one of the reasons we have programs like
Social Security we don't trust you to
keep your own money and put it in a 401k
account we believe that you're gonna
take that money and blow it on whatever
you're gonna blow it on are you worried
that that we grant ubi and then people
just don't spend it on health insurance
or they don't spend it on saving for the
future instead they just spend it on
whatever they're going to spend it on it
provides a temporary boost for the
economy and we're back in the same
position because people at lower levels
at least people who tend to stay at
lower levels people who are permanently
poor in the United States don't tend to
make great decisions with their money
are you concerned about that yeah it's a
concern for sure and one of the things
that that drives me is that there's been
a lot of research over the fact that if
you're poor if you're stressed out about
your month-to-month bills it actually
consumes a lot of your mental bandwidth
and it reduces your decision-making
ability reduces your functional
intelligence by 13 IQ points or one
standard deviation and so if you get the
boot off of someone's throat and say
look you're going to
here your kid's gonna be here all be
well then like their incentives to save
will hopefully be higher now I'm not
naive enough to think that like
everyone's gonna go and like do exactly
what you know I would see as like
optimally responsible with with their
money but big picture to return to your
original point I think it's their money
like I think that if you're a citizen
and shareholder of this country you know
and we can easily afford a dividend of
$1,000 a month and if you make a bad
decision or a decision I would consider
like poor in January you know maybe make
a better decision in February maybe make
a decision to March but it's going to be
up to you it's going to be you know your
life your choices and I certainly do not
think that the government saying like
hey we think you should just use the
money on this or that like would be a
better way to go there's a pretty
libertarian idea actually so that
doesn't seem to fit necessarily wholly
within sort of the Democratic belief
that manemma chronic party side that
when money is signed to you that we we
have to kind of stand guard over the
money there are a lot of libertarians
who believe in ubi and they have the
same core sort of libertarian view which
is your money you do with it what you
want you live with the consequences
obviously that comes with with downsides
from I I think the the left-wing point
of view well you know I think many
Americans have lost confidence that what
we need is another program where someone
comes in and says hey you know what we
think is best for you this so you know I
mean I like I think many Americans are
gonna be very excited about not being
able to make their own decisions on this
so let's talk about the the cost side of
this you proposed a value at attacks you
point out that Europe there is value
added tax which is essentially a
consumption tax you you want to add that
on top of the income tax and the
business tax as opposed to replacing it
if we were talking about replacing it
I'm on board with you man I'm totally
for a VAT replacing whatever income tax
system we have right now where do you
think the breaking point is as far as
how much the system can support in terms
of taxation right now we're living
pretty heavily on debt obviously yeah
and adding a bunch of new costs in the
form of you bi or quashing economic
growth to a certain extent because as
you increase the tax rate a certain
point you're gonna hit a breaking point
where do you think the tax the ideal tax
realized you're setting the taxes
how does the ideal tax system work well
I agree with you that ideally we are not
taxing labor in the same way we do now
because you don't want to tax things you
need more of and in my opinion we need
as much work and work like arrangement
as possible
and so ideally you would find ways to
tax things that are not labor
arrangements and so when you say like
hey if you like swap out you know you go
to Isis for like consumption tax you're
on board that to me should be the long
term vision the question is how you get
from here to there and so the way I
would start is by implementing this
value-added tax that path the European
level is quite modest but it would help
capture some of the gains that Amazon
and these other mega tech companies are
experiencing and return those gains to
the American people and some of it will
float back up to you know Jeff in it and
Jeff and Amazon again because you'll
just buy an extra toaster but you know
you like a lot of it will go to your
local restaurants and the mechanic and
the tutoring service and the hardware
store and you know it'll help replenish
that the Main Street economy and create
jobs but there is to me like a movement
in that direction that we need to get to
because right now we're just taxing in
my opinion or we're taxing highly and
efficiently and you look around and the
the way that we're trying to address
this is like hey you know it's like
there's like this high marginal tax rate
I try to explain to people all the time
look Jeff Bezos is worth 160 billion
dollars and most of that is Amazon stock
and it went from zero dough being worth
160 million dollars and he's way too
smart to have a taxable event like I can
ratchet up the marginal tax rate very
very high and it's not gonna help
anything this is exactly by the way what
was in the 1950s when people say that
there was a 91 top tax tax bracket in
the nineteen fifties no one paid that
percentage because there were a bunch of
loopholes in the law that allowed people
to escape paying that percentage the
effective marginal tax bracket at that
point was effectively the same as it is
today people are paying basically the
same amount of taxes yeah like people
are very very smart they're very very a
lot of those people right I mean that
this is tax avoidance is is a strategy
and people people will do that some of
our smartest friends in law school like
or help people avoid taxes right now of
course so and by the way one of the
things that's fun about talking to you
is that you and I have very similar
backgrounds
worked for a law firm for legitimately
ten months I was like I can't do this I
am out there's just no way to do this I
don't ask you one more question about
you be items more of a general question
they don't get to some of your other
proposals because one of the things
that's so fascinating about your
candidacy is that you have proposals
from here up to your a policy heavy dude
so on you bi final question which is how
much can money actually do I wrote an
entire book which right now is doing
very well the right side of history in
which I talked about I think the the the
lack of meaning and purpose in people's
lives and I wonder whether signing a
check is going to actually alleviate
that in any real way it seems like
there's been a loss of social capital
and social fabric they can't necessarily
be filled with a government program and
that no matter what government program
we propose if that social capital is not
restored through certain basic beliefs
in fundamental principles of the country
certain freedoms and certain beliefs and
community and and the kind of charitable
organization that you are the head of
that it's going to be very difficult for
people to find meaning even if they're
making a little more money because the
fact is we're the wealthiest country in
the history of the world people are
exorbitantly wealthy the poorest among
us I mean the rich would have been
clamoring in 1880 or for that matter in
1920 to live like the poorest among us
live now so is there can we fill what is
effectively a spiritual hole with a
government program this is to me the
generational challenge that we're facing
is how do you create more community ties
and structure and purpose and
fulfillment and pass forward for
Americans who feel this central void in
their lives
and of course like a thousand bucks a
month does not fill that void but and
here's to me that the path forward is if
you take a town in Missouri with 50,000
adults and they're struggling with that
sense of purpose and then you say hey
good news
now there's another 50 million dollars
in your community every month so what
happens to that money some of it goes
into local businesses there's a person
there who wanted to start a bakery and
the bakery was a dumb idea but now the
bakery is a good idea yeah then he
starts it then he hires a couple of
people and then people like his baked
goods and then some of that money goes
into religious institutions some of that
money goes into nonprofits some of that
money goes into arts organizations and
cultural organizations and then you end
up giving people an opportunity to be
start
to address that new sense of structure
and purpose and fulfillment and meaning
by making it so that everyone feels like
they have some value that aren't gonna
die like that you know like their kids
have a future and then putting at least
the beginning of some resources into
their hands to try and rebuild and maybe
for some of them it's like hey now I'm
going to leave this town like like that
could be the way like I'm gonna rebuild
but that to me is the generational
challenge how do you restore that sense
of self-worth and social capital and the
rest of it so it's not like money does
that but what money does do is that
money helps create the conditions where
we can at least start to try and address
that central challenge okay so now I
want to race through some of the policy
proposals own get one out of the way
immediately because people think the
reason you came on here was to discuss
circumcision which was not the reason
you came on the show and not the reason
I asked you on the show
so your position on circumcision your
anti circumcision but you are not in
favor of banning it is that correct yeah
that's totally right
I mean um you know I've two young boys
and you know when the first was born my
wife dug into various you know reasons
for circumcising you at your there are
kids and then she was unconvinced and
then she convinced me to be unconvinced
so we say but I've attended my friend's
bris for their their son and you know
it's up to parents what they want to do
and certainly for any like a religious
or cultural reason like people should
should be free to to adopt or they want
for their children so fine recall I
think because you know there's some the
medical evidence is at best conflicting
sometimes it's trendy sometimes it's not
there's talk about you know you're the
prevention of penile cancer you're an
area tract infection and stuff but you
know the fact is that as long as you're
not looking to ban it I don't care right
your perspective on it is your
perspective five and I have to say how
taken aback I was at what a thing it
became you know let me ask you about
that because the stupidity of the
Internet is truly astonishing if you
look at your candidacy online and you
look how the media cover it they cover
it not as just a mainstream candidacy of
ideas but as something weird and curious
because you have a lot of particularly
young white men who follow you online
and because you speak about the middle
of the country that largely has not been
talked about there's a lot of focus
right now in the Democratic Party on the
problems of races
or sexism or bigotry and you've talked
about some of those things but you've
talked more about the fact that there's
essentially an underclass of people many
of whom are white living in the middle
of the country in an area where
technology is eliminating their jobs and
the media have thus limited have thus
labelled you some sort of near alt
writer where do you think this is coming
from you know mean like I think that we
need to start just trying to have like
honest conversations about the problems
on the ground in this country and
certainly that's my goal as a candidate
I'm not quite sure where like I've been
frankly a little bit surprised by the
odds don't quite fit the description but
you know I'm happy to say that now we're
rising to a point because I'm pulling at
3% and we're raising you know hundreds
of thousand dollars per week and
everything else that the mainstream
media will now have to reckon with this
set of ideas but I agree with you that
the the media response to us has been
curious I'm about to become much more
mainstream I believe and I you know it's
but it's been an education for me okay
so I want to ask you about your
perspective on healthcare so you talk in
your book the the war on normal people
you talk about what you would do with
the healthcare system and you recommend
a single-payer health care system
obviously I'm a massive opponents of a
single-payer health care system that is
acknowledging the problems in our
employment-based health care system
that's something I think both of us
agree on and I'd prefer a system where
people are effectively paying for their
own health care so that they can
actually see the cost of what it is that
they are consuming and then we can form
coalition's as we do and associations to
to help defray the cost for people who
have pre-existing conditions and all the
rest you recommend a single-payer health
care system why do you think that's the
best option well I think you and I might
have had similar experiences where if
you run a small company you know you're
you see that our current employment
based system is a real weight on the
economy where it makes it harder to hire
people it makes it harder to treat
someone as a full-time employee because
you have these inside of to treat them
as a contractor it makes it harder to
start a business and makes it harder to
change jobs it's like this massive
source of friction and so the question
is how do you separate health care from
your employment situation is right now
you can imagine how many more
entrepreneurs there'd be in the US if
they didn't have to stress out about
health care for themselves their
families I mean there'd be many many
more people starting businesses now I
agree with you that there has to be some
kind of skin in the game like it can't
be that if you just show up it's like
always cost-free because you know there
are some people that are hypochondriac
so like consume a lot of treatment so
there should be some sort of individual
skin the game that's said I feel that
health care is an environment where the
market is going to be an imperfect
solution because one you get very cost
insensitive if you have a serious
illness or your loved one is seriously
ill - it's like the pricing is very
confusing and opaque you know and then
you're relying upon specialists for
various pieces of information to say oh
you need this you don't need that and so
it's not like like the same sort of
market as many many other consumer goods
or experiences where you can trust that
like you know you're going to say like
hey I'm educated on what that product
means for me so I think that we need to
try and get the cost down and right now
we're living in the worst of all worlds
where we're spending twice as much in
our health care as other societies -
worse results and it's a massive
impediment to our economy and hiring and
dynamism so I just think that having a
robust public option you can improve the
access bring down the costs just because
we're saddled with this incredibly
inefficient system right now so there
are a couple of points to be made in
defense of the American healthcare
system you know putting aside the
employment basis which i think is deeply
wrong and was initiated in response to
actually wage controls in the 1940s and
that one of the things to be said is
that when it comes to five-year cancer
survival rates the United States still
ranks number one when you remove
homicide and car accident the United
States still has the longest life
expectancy
yes we're expensive but if you look at
us on a per GDP per capita GDP basis
we're actually not all that far out of
the realm of possibility because the
fact is that we're a very wealthy
country people are choosing to spend we
do develop more than half of all new
medical patents so there's some upsides
so the fact that we have a market in
healthcare and one thing I do want to
say is I would not it like I'm not for a
system where we're somehow eliminating
private insurers where there would be
these gold-plated concierge probably
private health plans that would still
have massive
financial incentives and resources for
various forms of innovation in the rest
of it so let there one point in the book
where he where you talk about doctors
and this I took a little personally in
the sense that as I've mentioned many
times my wife is a doctor she's gone
through 1 million years of training at
this she find looking what kind of
doctor she's a family medicine doc and
she will assure her yes she'll be
finishing her residency this upcoming
June and literally since we were dating
she's been on this path right she wants
it we got married when she was a junior
in college and then she did a couple of
years working in a lab and then she went
to medical school and now she's in
residency I'm doing the math I'm doing
the math we met Rob years exactly almost
11 years in July so well done so she's
been doing this for a very long time and
you talk in the book about this idea
that we're gonna have to shift how
doctors think of doing their jobs and
you sort of suggest that doctors are
gonna have to become more altruistic
than instead of seeing this profession
as a way of making money they're gonna
have to see it as just you'll make some
money but you won't make enormous money
the fact is that you're not going to get
people to go through a 10 to 12 year
system of education if you're telling
them on the other end they're gonna get
paid like postal postal workers
absolutely not a postal workers but
$150,000 a year I mean the fact is that
thank god I've been able to pay for my
wife's education this whole way but if
we had not then she was working below
minimum wage for in her residency
because she's working hours and hours
and hours and even that's 50 grand a
year she's working legitimately eighteen
ninety hours a week and then she has
most of her colleagues have hundreds of
thousands of dollars in medical school
debt and they're gonna have to pay all
of that off it seems to me that if we
have a supply and demand problem we need
to increase the supply of doctors and
the way to do that is to actually
incentivize people to join the medical
profession not by telling them that they
need to be paid less in the name of
altruism but they need to be paid more
for through through transparency and
pricing and being able to decide their
own standards well have you seen why our
supply of doctors is constrained I mean
yes I mean people people don't want to
deal with the administration they don't
want to deal with the insurance it's
because the the doctors and the medical
so one it's kind of a medical licensing
as well yes yes it's incredibly
expensive to educate a doctor and the
supply has been constrained for years
even as many many communities have
become what's called primary care
deserts because when someone and there's
one reason why I'm congratulating your
wife on being a family medicine doctor
is that what
she's in training she's racking up all
this debt and then she's like wait a
minute if I specialize in certain things
I'll get paid a lot more than if I
become a primary care doctor and if I
live someplace where they can you know
like afford to pay me more than I live
better than if I go to some rural
community or a small town or something
where maybe they don't have a doctor
like me maybe they could really use a
doctor like me but you know my life is
gonna be harder I'm gonna get paid less
etc so right now to me you are 100%
right that we need to increase the
supply but it's not a compensation issue
we just need to increase the supply
because right now the doctors and the
medical schools have not created new
paths to train doctors and that's been a
problem for years and decades
well it's certainly true that we have to
deregulate a lot of medical licensing so
you're a libertarian on that one too I
mean it sounds like well you know having
nurse practitioners being able to do
more things would be a very good thing
yes particularly when we get really good
AI and this is something the doctors
have fought is that if you were to say
to a doctor or the doctors lobby group
it's like hey there's a primary care
like we need to send someone over there
and they need to be able to treat
patients doctors been like no you know
needs to be an MD right and then you're
like but wait there's no MD there
literally and none of you wants to move
there and so we need to make it so that
nurse practitioners can do more and this
is particularly true when we're going to
have AI that can at least help diagnose
a significant proportion of conditions
and recommend treatment and then you can
always refer to a doctor if it's you
know if it's helpful we add all this but
I think the question is when it comes to
Medicare for all the truth is that fewer
people are going into the medical
profession they're choosing people to be
lawyers they're choosing to be a
businessmen specifically because they
don't want to deal with the hassle of
the government there are lots of doctors
increasingly who won't even take
Medicare they'd rather take private
insurance because the Medicare and
reimbursement rates are 60% and you are
mandated to get through a certain number
of patients in many cases if you're
working one of these hospitals to shift
so right now there's a double whammy
going on and so what you're suggesting
is like hey it's because of low
reimbursement rates which is certainly
an issue but the other issue that's a
tendon which is at least as important is
just the amount of bureaucracy and
paperwork and administration and like oh
these doctors I'm friends with because
I'm Asian I have a lot of doctor friends
where where they say it's like I'd love
to be just actually be seeing a patient
but instead for every you know like ten
minutes I spend with a patient like I'm
spending or one of my staffers is
spending you know four minutes on like
documentation or administration or
billing a lot of that has to do medical
liability yeah a lot of that has to do
as well with with regulation of these
insurance companies and lack of
transparency because the truth is if you
walk into a doctor's office right now
and you ask a doctor how much an x-ray
cost they have no idea they don't admit
it to the insurance company yes a lot of
this seems like regulatory problems to
me not necessarily to be cured by the
collective-bargaining of Medicare well
we've created this incredibly like
Byzantine labyrinth yeah and so the
question is how do you clean it up and
how do you free up doctors to actually
focus on patients and care rather than
billing codes and paperwork and that is
the path that we have to take now
they're different you know like people
can can have different approaches but
that is to me where we can go totally
agree and to me that the most obvious
example of the free market at work is
concierge care and you're starting to
see this rise you're seeing apps that
are designed to have doctors just arrive
at your door the doctor comes to you in
many cases so it seems to me that that
you know will differ on this but it
seems the free market your free markets
actually do apply and obtained in the
vast majority of cases when it comes to
healthcare just like they do anything
else in declaring something not a good
doesn't make it more plentiful or more
robust yes so let me just say that I
think bureaucracy is the enemy and my
goal would be to diminish it not elevate
it okay so let's talk for a second about
some of the other proposals some of them
I think are fun I totally agree with you
the n-c-double-a should pay athletes
frankly I think that we should stop
college athletics altogether which I
will say right in the middle of March
Madness
I don't even care man because the fact
is that if you're going to college and
you're going to a top college not to
actually get a degree but we're gonna
basically bring you here for a year so
that you can have a tryout for the NBA
and then they're gonna make millions of
dollars off you totally on board with
that one let's talk about the green new
deal so you are you say you're aligned
and on board with the green new deal
which part of it I assume not the part
for unable and unwilling to work in
killing the farting cows I'm for the
fact that climate change is a is a
growing threat where the last four years
have been the four warmest years and
recorded
human history and that our projections
about what's going to happen
unfortunately are getting steadily worse
and so the question is is there
something that we can do about it and
this is a space where the government to
me has to play a key role because the
financial incentives right now are
towards forms of energy that that you
know are just more developed and more
economically advantageous at this point
so if someone says hey we need to move
dramatically in a direction towards
renewable energy like I applaud that
vision because I think that is where we
need to go the way I disagree with some
people some other people on this is that
we sometimes pretend that the United
States is somehow 100 percent of global
emissions we're about 15 percent and so
even if we were to go whole hog we would
probably diminish the rate incremental e
and so I'm for trying to address and
mitigate the worst effects of a warming
planet with the recognition that it's
probably going to happen whether we move
towards renewable sources of energy or
not so this is hilarious because you and
I aren't exactly the same page on this
also you've endorsed nuclear power for
example or many of your colleagues have
to have I don't even know how it's
possible to say that you want to reduce
global warming but you're also against
nuclear power that just seems completely
mad to me yeah I mean nuclear has to be
a big part of the the solution if you're
gonna head in this direction okay so
let's talk also about it this is what
one of the things I really enjoy about
your candidacy is that you you do have
so many ideas and some of them are
really kind of heterodox so you want to
revive earmarks and you talk about
reviving earmarks it's actually
something that it's a third rail of
politics you're not allowed to say that
you're in favor of earmarks but the
truth is that the death of earmarks has
actually led to budget impasses because
people have no incentive to freaking
bargain with anymore it's like you know
I show up in your office I'm like hey we
got to make a deal like what are you
gonna do for me it's like I can't do
anything it's saying that's no way to
get anything done yeah so and that's it
that's a practical policy one of the
areas were where I do wonder about the
practicality of is you say that you're
in favor of a four week paid leave
policy for all full-time workers and you
say it's a mandatory four week paid
leave policy so can you explain what you
mean by that well so I think it was a
you know it's like there were
projections that our work weeks we get
shorter and shorter overtime as became
more
octave and people were projecting like a
15 hour work week but unfortunately
other direction and studies and studies
have shown that it's not necessarily
that our productivity is in lockstep
with the amount of time we spend and so
I think that a certain amount of time
off and I would exempt various small
businesses and the rest of it that you
know that that it might somehow be
disruptive to your operations but
generally speaking I think time off is
good for people it's good for
organizations it's good for processes
like when I ran a company I would tell
people to take time off and they would
never do it and they wouldn't do it
because I wasn't doing it and then when
I realized okay I get it I need to do it
and then you will do it and then lo and
behold you know I think like I'd come
back refreshed and with like a different
outlook or new ideas and the same would
happen for them and so to me you know
it's a good way for an organization to
have to like evolve and adapt so that
it's not like you have to be on the like
firing line at the front line all the
time I mean listen I very much love to
take four weeks of vacation this year I
highly doubt that I will despite the
Jewish holidays I guess my question is
whenever you have the government sort of
just creating goods
isn't that a damper on the economy and
also aren't you gonna get the same thing
that you have with the tax code where
basically businesses just hire part-time
workers businesses just decide that
they're going to hire independent
contractors they're not subject to to
such regulations you know again I mean
we'd have exemptions for people so I'm
sure that in your case if you do not
want to take four weeks I'm sure you
would not what can I say yeah so you
know like the goal is not somehow make
it harder for businesses to operate and
I understand that the margins it might
seem like that that's the case like it
to me it actually helps make
organizations more sustainable and
somewhat more organic so one of the
other things that you've talked about is
getting the government involved and sort
of how we consume information so you've
talked about the Department of the
attention economy which would basically
the government policing the amount of
time on social media you know I don't
necessarily time but also just the way
the social media apps are designed
because like one of my friends Tristan
Harris who worked on it it's like look
we're just we have brilliant engineers
turning these supercomputers into slot
machines they're hip
sizing teenage girls and like making
everyone depressed you know and that's
where their financial incentives are so
it's not just time on the app it's
actually the way the object design Mindy
do you fear that giving the government
that kind of power leads to the the
power of censorship obviously there been
a lot of complaints from the right from
people who are heterodox politically
that the social media companies are
cracking down in particular political
points of view putting the government in
charge of of this sort of stuff can
easily slide over into government
censorship where they say that they are
policing the form of the app but in
reality what they're actually policing
is the the form of consumption of
content you do worry about that you know
like I feel like those concerns are
somewhat less pressing than they were at
a time when when we had limited means of
accessing information or consuming
information like if you have intention
if you if you were like a just like
snapchats design algorithms where it's
like hey you know like stop pinging the
the teenage kid all the time like I'm
optimistic that that would not
necessarily curb people's access to
quality political information one of the
things that you've talked about if I'm
not mistaken is you've talked about sort
of a kind of regulation of the news
media where the government police is the
sort of information being distributed as
news that's where I start to get a
really frightened because the fact is
that the government in the business of
news yeah whether you are a fan of Trump
or not a fan of Trump if you are on the
right you're afraid of Barack Obama
doing missed you if you're on the Left
are afraid of Donald Trump doing this to
you how exactly do you restrict the
powers of government when it comes to
intervention and that sort of stuff well
so I was looking at some of the models
abroad because right right now we're in
a bit of a mess in terms of our
information consumption there are very
powerful market dynamics where if I'm a
well if I'm like a you know a media
company I figure out ooh if I cater to
getting like you know the most extreme
30 percent like excited I think that's
actually better for my business than
being more like moderate it's like it's
like click bait but click bait across
information silos and so I looked at
what some other countries have done and
that if someone has like demonstrably
false information then you come and say
look like that was actually like you
know like fabricated and then just opted
to issue an apology or there's some kind
of process but we're at a point now
where we legitimately have a hard time
agreeing on facts and we have at least
some four and
actors that are taking advantage of like
this soft underbelly to sort of gin up
various like groups against each other
and make it so that people can't even
trust what they're seeing and this is
before deep fakes and the rest of it
arrive where literally they could show
you and I like do it doing something and
then it's like well it must be real
because the internet so so it's a mess
and it's the situation where you have to
look at it with like a you know
perspective and say okay it's a mess and
that's gonna get Messier like what are
possible ways out of this and at least
to me they're like you know the
government may have a role to play in
saying this is fake this is fraudulent
this is from a foreign actor this is
like not is not true in the absence of
any sort of action in that that
direction then we're in for an even
worse environment in terms of
polarization in my opinion I mean to me
the obviously there are the responses
that the government empowering them to
determine what is true and false
sometimes shades over into an opinion on
a fact and the government decides that
this is what politifact does to us on a
regular basis and it gets into a little
bit of dangerous territory in a second I
want to ask you about race I have one
final question for you which is where do
we stand racially in the country but if
you want to hear Andrew Yang's answer
you actually have to be a daily wire
subscriber to subscribe head on over to
daily we're calm click Subscribe you can
hear the end of our conversation over
there well thank you so much for
stopping by it really means a lot I
think it's a great discussion I'm sure
that our listeners are gonna have a lot
of thoughts in response if people want
to give to your campaign they can check
out away yang 2020 calm yes yeah in 2020
calm or just Google Andrew yang but
would certainly love to have everyone's
help and support in this campaign is
we're gonna make history together we're
gonna bring the revolution of reason to
the American people it's not left or
right it's forward well thank you so
much I really appreciate Andrew thanks
for stopping by thank you Ben spanner
pleasure
[Music]
the men Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Kluber edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Kula the
Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]